With shadowing and lighting now wrapped up,
we have finished our Groom introduction.
We first started this course by taking a look at what Groom was and
how you can use it to achieve some very lifelike-looking hair
and fur and whatever real-time project you're using on RealEngine 5.
We then looked at how we enable the Groom plugin.
We imported some Groom assets.
We explored the various Groom tool settings.
We then looked at how to create a very simple Groom material
using the Material Editor and the Hair Attribute node.
We then looked at how we can apply Grooms to assets in both our levels and
Blueprints and followed that up with Groom shadowing and lighting,
and how the various settings will affect
the shadowing and lighting of our Groom assets.
It was my pleasure having you in class today,
and I look forward to seeing you next time.
Thank you.